oh that can't exclusive yo ty 975 Ready
Set Radio bamboo by cab here with one of
my favorite hip-hop groups we got
slaughterhouse yeah word word I am one
on one of your favorite hip-hop groups I
must save you some time I'm around the
whole nine oh thank you man you talking
about our demo Scott no come on in the
EP was up it was whatever but I'll just
put that out just get out of the
contract right q60 you are really
keeping it funky hahaha he before the
hour got back on the sea was my joint we
play there on my on my show your himself
but uh men hey welcome to Las Vegas
manatee y'all not performed as a group
here yet yes yeah yeah you have yes okay
well maybe was here oh that's right
that's right I wasn't here yet i was i
was in boise idaho when you're on it so
I saw the toronado do I was not there
something I want your family yeah yeah
man but hey welcome to the city um charm
to the hammer dance right off the joint
right now thank you ma'am um guys work
with a wrap hey rap music yeah everyone
grab music yes yes Sean on a round you
guys heard that beat man it's it's a
very it's a very slaughterhouse be in
common and that's the single did you
guys hear it and think right away a lot
of times if you catch arabi don't think
okay this yo you know it's the single
right away wasn't something that you
guys have recorded in US side down and
kind of trip it out maybe there was
going to be single it was a kind of
light of the way from a rap plays so
many beats when he came to Detroit yeah
and that was one of those beats that I
heard we heard we heard them within a
series of beads names and then I went
home like five in the morning crooked
and joelle for some reason still had a
whole bunch of energy left so they lay
vs hey MA and Joey came back to the
studios like what in HD LOL so forget
your second date y'all did a hook did
you guys come up with no they did two
verses and you guys came together they
just laid vs okay yeah this one came
with the hook
lookit Thank You Man he came with the I
ain't even know that the record was
going where was gone when we lady we
just know we like to be yeah we wanted
to go on their spit you know nickel came
in and just demolished up the mileage to
thank you man so the debut album
dropping in june right jun 12 jun 12 you
have a relationship with with primo
you're like you've got have free will be
on this happening anything like confirm
this can give you his number he was here
he's like he said about to go in with
y'all that was like don't you want you
that's what you've been telling me too
okay you know I thought wrong but that's
that's like that's my big brother
exactly i'm like you guys got classics
together yeah i mean me and praying man
i mean the reason why second cohesive
the ways of cohesive this thing on it
the go he stiffness is there so much is
because we vibe so much just as people
with each other you know i'm saying so
train was definitely more than just
somebody that I'm working with he's my
friend and I don't call a lot of people
that most definitely this far how's the
reception being on the tour a pretty
good to me pretty good pretty good have
you guys succeed in our expectation
probably seen you guys like five times
like all together you guys like switched
up the songs they represent each other
cities yet no no just good it was a
naughty by nature right for Joey twist
over my bro my fashion come up come on
to a red man song time now are there any
like about you know what a straight man
joint honestly I tried that prior to
them and everybody was like my nature
song and it didn't go over so well yeah
with some of these younger kids I they
don't know what's up man yeah didn't
work out the way I talk to choose from
me haha you know what but what what's
funny about that is there's really a lot
to choose from from New Jersey just
nothing so courage and nothing there
like is like huge like you know you play
naughty by nature that's something that
everybody knows anyone you know of
course when you guys do that part
oh you know it's it really you know life
is a crowd of like when you know you
drop Hypnotizer 10 a lot of me in
comparison to the other cities and other
other records that can be played from
these cities naughty I certainly I gotta
go got naughty by default we got naughty
by nature very redneck look good hahaha
when it comes to uh when it comes to
tour with each other i've been i've been
checking out your guys's blogs and
they're very entertained by the way i'd
love to hear that story you were going
to tell about being at the radio station
with tragic off the air cuz word yeah um
shut up treasures yong wang yeah hey
what you guys when you guys when you
guys decided to do those it seems like
like each one of you guys is hosting
like each you know there's like Joelle
hosting one voice host one um whose idea
was that man because that's actually
really don't be kind of like let's
everybody into everyone's personality a
little bit young keno low-key I do Loki
oh hello Russell Simmons young kind of
this dude yeah balmain brown in there
hey so what is it like you guys record
most album in Detroit or what yeah we
did I said good question yeah I think
Nick the bulk of it will hide yeah well
yeah there it is yeah we definitely did
a book a book it's not a mere elevated
in Detroit yeah you know we are planned
trips around our individual schedules we
locked in for weeks at a time flew
producers in no listening to be CDs here
we had actual produce has come rain and
nobody does that anymore yeah and
they're so Israel it was real organic it
real good oh and his em got any
production on the album yes he does yeah
so i haven't heard much in production it
was like a surgeon's of introduction for
like two or three years and he kind of
kind of went away for a little bit well
you'll hear some on this one hey i got a
question man cuz I've been a big fan of
all for you guys for a long time your
solo careers especially Joey I was real
big fan of all the movie
thank you um yeah what would you say was
with me they're kind of own yes the limb
but all right I word it out haha dogs
Lou yo how much does he know bless hate
you offer I'm saying I know that we
window the song slaughterhouse had y'all
and you know bless and he just he does
didn't get on the bus which are I guess
or it wasn't invited you guys who I mean
I was wondering ain't no Nina was a
random thing I'll not need no one's
fresh Nina was fresh needle is a dope
lyrices he just didn't really fit the
criteria like all of us have been in the
game you got your all the hands Devon
had your own you know I'm saying so it
just made more sense that way but you
don't shut out needle he he definitely
first of all he told me he was
responsible for waking Joey up to me
that's what he told me so how worried I
got a salute him for that okay if
nothing else d hey Tori woohoo you guys
like click up at all I mean if you guys
have disagreements I mean how does that
work out you guys just go to your bunks
play video games or without some call
meeting house everyone just sits down I
think it was what's up yeah we gotta
have a meeting now I gots not flushing
the toilet yo like I should ain't go on
the bus homie stuff like that nothing no
no we don't do that on trust yeah like
that you guys got like no groupie policy
on the bus anything like that I don't
some rappers no girls on the bus sir we
don't really be messing with roofies fan
aren't you married boys yeah I'm Mary
I'm very happily married that's what I'd
like is like to get about ski skinny
jeans on the bars answering this table
didn't come away with me yo classic um
what else can we expect from the album
man I mean so highly anticipated shady
records debut
look I mean the science of course
lyricism I mean how is it different from
the first time you can expect hooks of
course a lot of wrapping and i'll just
put number of Iraq any rap rap I mean
are you guys you guys feel pressure of
course you guys are gonna stay true to
to what you guys do and that's you know
you guys wanted a few entities that
really represent us if I favorite word
but just what she was jun 12 already my
nose yeah y'all feeling in my personal
opinion like I feel like we are so good
at what we do yeah why even feel
pressure I'm saying you guys feel
personally my question with you feel
pressure to compromise remarkably no we
don't have to compromise anything like I
know I know us old game is about the
light shining on you right and a whole
lot of people actually paying attention
to what you do creatively you gonna
deliver every time every time and one
like the compromise would be crazy when
you when your CEO is imminent did you
know I don't sell like a he has a
compromise I just one bar I just as we
started recently that we're under the
tutelage arguably notice that I'm using
the word arguably pray arguably the
greatest artists of our time we're under
his tutelage you know I'm saying like I
get a phone call yo you think Joelle
should change his line Joelle talk to
him Joelle yo I'll change it right away
you know I'm saying like we like this
process is easy man this is easy work
it's easy work you're me do this for so
long man it's crazy hey being outed well
being that you you haven't once
previously on the situation with Drake
it didn't work out
and now you sign in the kind of weirdo
no it's not weird at all the situation
with your trail but after that it was a
was my decision to leave right it was a
release date issue you know I'm saying I
felt like I was hot enough and had
enough steam and enough records hand
within and things that I made sure to
drop my album I'm saying and you know
they had told me at the time to wait on
a detox and we still you two still been
waiting oh man i don't i don't know but
um yes i opted opted to leave the label
it was another sour breaker brain right
goes although except that dre wanted to
keep you don't sound like you know it
was tough on it be like you know let me
tell you like I got plans did you ever
do any um goes riding for drag when you
were there yeah we did okay for anything
Josh mother's day probably my findings
over yeah yeah Drake on the or detox
album but I mean this is a whole new
situation yeah yes this is pace it's
really refreshing because like I gotta
give props to eminem man because the
climate right now and my commercial
hip-hop is very crazy for a massage when
I get the keys on his all right are you
guys right I mean he signed us because
when I don't know we wanted to sign up
for a minute right but you got each had
your own separate it with for solo
artist first and foremost so you know we
had to work out contracts and things you
know we had obligations totally they
need to be worked out but yeah he signed
us because we're dope so getting back to
compromise and that's not an issue
because you know what's funny is when
i'm ross on the bag when BAM ET believe
you drive and you guys brought Bruno
Mars I'm everybody the phone over Cuba
mean to ask you like how much I wish it
were taking back your voice 25 not to do
like you know you you get a catalog
underground classics like is there any
any guys like hopping on hooks like that
that might surprise you record fan base
on that way I don't want to divulge that
information but one thing that I feel
about that
do people get our fans of us that make
us feel like they only love us because
we haven't made it yet yeah it's like
then then you make it into hate you if
it's left [__] said I don't know I
don't know how to feel about those
people because it's like yo do you
really if you're really champion for us
that's underground artists that are
underdogs wouldn't you want for us to
make it so me doing a song with Bruno
Mars is a that that's like a plateau in
my career yet that should be a good
thing that shouldn't be a bad thing he's
it he's an incredibly talented artist
right why can't i work with him why
because i have aggressive content when I
rap yeah I don't I don't understand it
yes I don't like understanding things
you know what everybody smart what did
it was like sometimes I think a lot of
these fans land and you're like you know
they own you kind of like not only did
it like like like sorry but your mother
receiver what the songwriters it's about
it's about triumph hmm it's about I'm
talking about trying to get my daddy out
of the post office know you and like
what's really than that like why
wouldn't you like that I'm talking about
trying to make something of myself I'm
not talking about killing nobody i'm not
talking about no negative it's a song
about trying to make it again everybody
should relate to yes like you know
what's so crazy man will lead we did the
New York show yes by theater sold out
well really aww did you hear me get to
that and um you know what's so crazy one
of the fans told me I liked it better
when I was the only one who knew about
you guys that's how it always is man I
see that so much especially lately like
over the last 45 years
hosen dude that you'll be like yo I love
j Cole and then he blows up and then
mantyhose weaponize it like six months
ago why can't you just say yo you know
what I was on to them before you was yes
watch that video bragging right because
at the end of the day we don't want to
let anybody down but we're going to
develop yeah well we're going to get a
match tomorrow and so whatever we're
going to become but we're not going to
allow ourselves to be in a box that fans
put us in I don't think that's fair to
us as artists we're creative people